oh hi on today's episode of game life
I'd like to talk to you about a subject
that is near and dear to my heart Mario
now if you're my age you also grew up
with Super Mario games and he watched as
Nintendo would delay these games for
years just to make sure that they all
had brilliant new ideas from flying with
a raccoon tail and Super Mario Brothers
32 throwing eggs around Yoshi's Island
Nintendo made sure that each new mario
game to do something brand-new now on
Sunday a nintendo released new super
mario brothers too for the nintendo 3ds
now it's a great game it's an excellent
game but the problem is just nine months
ago they released Super Mario 3d Land
for EDS and that game is so much better
than New Super Mario Brothers to it is
it cold there in your own shadow Mario
do you enjoy playing second fiddle to
yourself what's more Nintendo is
releasing new super mario brothers you
as a day one title for the wii u later
this year that's three Mario games in
the span of one year and that's not even
counting spin-offs like Paper Mario
which is also coming out in November
what is the reason for this massive
Mario marathon it's not too hard to
understand the 2d new super mario
brothers series has been a sales
juggernaut it is outsold even the 3d
mario galaxy style games by millions of
copies worldwide and with the Nintendo
3ds in trouble and the wii u's chances
of success not exactly certain nintendo
knows it has to put its best foot
forward so it's cranking out new super
mario brothers games like there's no
tomorrow nintendo isn't just resting on
a tube almost new super mario brothers
too has the coin rush mode which adds an
interesting multiplayer element and new
super mario brothers you has the assist
mode in which a second player can use
the wii u's touchscreen control
to add blocks into the game the problem
is this is just bad optics Nintendo has
gone from sitting on Mario games until
their unique concerning them out at
lightning speed and they all look the
same this Nintendo want to make Mario
into call of duty the reason the Mario
series has sold millions of copies every
single time for 30 years is precisely
because Nintendo doesn't burn players
out they space the releases out they
make you wait a little while and they
take that time to do something new now
if you don't think that burnout could
ever happen to Mario just look at the
Zelda series Nintendo used to release a
legend of zelda game like once every
five years and players were able to
build up that level of anticipation now
they seem to release one every year or
so and what happened well legend of
zelda spirit tracks in japan started
getting blown out in bargain bins for
just five bucks nintendo if you don't
want this to happen to the Mario series
you've got to give the poor guy a
well-deserved break that's it for this
week see you next time on game life